mind your decisions I'm prestel Walker
an equilateral triangle is inscribed in
a unit square what is the area of the
equilateral triangle pause the video if
you'd like to give this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
so how can we solve this problem let's
write s for the length of the
equilateral triangle side the square has
a side length of 1 now in this right
triangle suppose the other leg is equal
to X by the Gogu theorem s squared is
equal to 1 squared plus x squared now
consider the following right triangle
its hypotenuse is also equal to s and
one of its legs is equal to 1 therefore
its other leg must also be equal to X
finally we have one more triangle
it must have legs of 1 minus X because
the entire length of the square side is
equal to 1 we therefore have s squared
is equal to 1 minus X the quantity
squared plus 1 minus X the quantity
squared well simplify this a little bit
and now we have two equations well
consider this system of equations we'll
subtract the second equation from the
first and the S squared terms will
cancel out we then get an equation in
one variable X we can routinely solve
this and we get a quadratic equation we
use the quadratic formula and then we
simplify to get two possibilities X is
equal to 2 minus root 3 and X is equal
to 2 plus root 3 now recall that X has
to be less than the side of the square
so X has to be between 0 & 1
therefore we reject 2 plus root 3 and we
accept 2 minus root 3 once we have the
value of x we can go ahead and solve for
s squared and then remember we're trying
to solve for the area of the equilateral
triangle which is equal to s squared
root 3 all over 4 we simplify this and
we get 2 root 3 minus 3 which is
approximately 0.46 4 and that's our
answer
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on YouTube as
always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
[Music]